[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de covile 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi anciens ministres et
directeurs généraux de la santé
lcp vous faire revivre tout l'été ces
auditions aujourd'hui une des plus
attendues celle d'agnès busin ministre
de la santé au tout début de ce qui
n'est pas encore une crise sanitaire
elle démissionne le 16 février pour
mener la campagne des municipales à
paris at-elle pris conscience de la
gravité de la situation
pourquoi les stocks de masques et et ils
vident des questions posées par les
députés de la commission denquête
regardez nous auditionnons aujourd'hui
madame agnès buzyn qui est accompagné de
son ancien directeur de cabinet monsieur
raymond lemoine
madame la ministre vous avez tenu au
début de l'année quand les premiers cas
de kovy dont on commençait à apparaître
en chine puis au lendemain du premier
tour des élections municipales
des propos qui ont pu vous être reproché
nous aurons certainement à y revenir
mais je voudrais aussi que cette
audition soit l'occasion de faire le
point des premières mesures de gestion
de la crise sanitaire que vous avez été
amené à prendre très rapidement
je veux parler de l'activation du centre
opérationnel de régulation et de réponse
aux urgences sanitaires et sociales
renforcer le chorus le 22 janvier puis
la mise en place du centre de crise
sanitaire au sein de la direction
générale de la santé le 27 janvier et
l'activation du plan or son moral
le 25 février janvier pardon la réserve
sanitaire été mobilisés les premières
saisines de santé publique france pour
les achats de masques et équipements
individuels de protection pour les
soignants sont lancés de façon plus
générale
pensez vous que l'organisation actuelle
du système de soins au niveau national
territoriale lui permet de faire face à
une crise sanitaire soudaine madame la
ministre monsieur avant de vous donner
la parole je vais vous demander de
prêter serment
je vous invite tous deux a levé la main
droite et dire je le jure
je le jure je je je vous remercie madame
la ministre vous avez la parole pour un
cours propos liminaire qui précédera
surtout notre échange sous forme de
questions réponses avant à l'isi je vous
laisse la parole m merci madame la
présidente madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés notre
pays
l'ensemble de la planète ont été
confrontés et pour certains le sont
encore à une épidémie inédite sans
précédent aux conséquences majeures sur
notre société et notre vie de tous les
jours pour notre pays nous ne sommes pas
sortis de l'épidémie nous sortons de la
phase aiguë et nous devons continuer à
faire face à beaucoup d'inconnues et
d'incertitudes comme l'ensemble des
autres pays de la planète moment où je
vous parle je pense douloureusement à
tous ceux qui parmi nous ont été touchés
soit par le deuil soit par la maladie à
tous ceux qui sont affectés par la crise
économique
je pense aussi à tous ceux qui ont été
en première ligne
ces hommes et ces femmes qui dans
l'ombre ont contribué à ce que nous
puissions continuer à vivre à nous
déplacer à être protégé je pense
évidemment aux professionnels de santé
quel que soit leur mode d'exercice qui
ont exercé leur mission en s'exposant
par construction plus que d'autres aux
risques de contamination
je pense au ministère la santé aux
agences régionales de santé qui ont été
mobilisés comme on ne peut pas
l'imaginer je pense aussi au service de
l'étang à l'ensemble des ministères qui
se sont réorganisés pour se mettre au
service d'une seule et unique priorité
la lutte contre l'épidémie
je pense sur collectivités locales aux
établissements de santé établissements
médico sociaux et aux établissements
sociaux qui ont tant fait pour prendre
en charge rassurer accompagner nos
concitoyens et notamment les plus
fragiles d'entre eux je pense aussi aux
scientifiques ou chercheurs qui se sont
mobilisés pour accélérer le déploiement
de protocoles de recherche dans tous les
domaines
et je pense à tous nos concitoyens qui
ont permis à la vie de continuer en
étant entendue devant vous je souhaite
pouvoir m'expliquer sur l'exercice des
responsabilités qui ont été les miennes
notamment à la tête d'un ministère dont
je veux redire aussi combien j'ai été
fier de le diriger et combien notre pays
a de la chance de pouvoir compter sur un
service de santé exceptionnelle
bien loin de la caricature de ce qu'ils
décrivent une faillite complète de notre
système de santé
oui notre pays a vu le meilleur et il
est tout aussi légitime de s'interroger
sur les faiblesses observées
c'est le propre de toutes les crises et
le travail à mener pour en tirer les
enseignements doit l'être en profondeur
et dans toutes ses dimensions
je sais que je serai aussi entendus sur
les raisons pour lesquelles j'ai quitté
mon ministère à un moment je le rappelle
de la phase initiale du risque
épidémique et sur ce que j'ai pu faire
pour préparer notre pays à ce type de
risque ainsi que sur les décisions que
j'ai piloté en direct je suis évidemment
prêtes de répondre à toutes vos
questions
merci madame la ministre avant de passer
la parole à monsieur le rapportage je
souhaite vous interroger sur deux points
précis
premièrement votre position vis-à-vis de
la gravité de la crise a été amenée à
évoluer à plusieurs reprises le 21
janvier par conférence de presse puis le
24 janvier
vous déclariez par exemple que le risque
d'importation du virus de chine
sa propagation était très faible lors de
votre entretien accordé au journal le
monde le 17 janvier
vous indiquez avoir su au moment de
votre départ du ministère de la santé
que je vous cite le tsunami était devant
nous sur le plateau de france inter le
28 mai vous déclarez cette fois ci en
parlant de votre regard sur l'épidémie
au moment de votre départ du ministère
des solidarités je ne savais pas quand
ça allait arriver
je ne connaissais ni l'ampleur ni la
gravité
alors que ces déclarations peuvent
apparaître contradictoire pourriez vous
nous indiquer précisément votre état des
connaissances est votre analyse du
risque posé par l'épidémie à partir du
mois de janvier et jusqu'à votre départ
le 16 février
deuxièmement je souhaite vous interroger
sur la question centrale légitime aux
yeux de nos compatriotes concernant la
gestion du stock de masques lors de son
audition le 17 juin dernier françois
bourdiaux ancien directeur général de
santé publique nous a indiqué une
mission à notre mission part dans une
lettre en date du 26 septembre 2018
adressée au directeur général de santé
monsieur jérôme salomon dans cette
missive sur la base du rapport du comité
d'experts présidé par le professeur jean
paul stahl monsieur baudillon recommandé
de constituer un stock de l'ordre d'un
milliard de masques et concluez cette
lettre par ses propos actuellement 95 %
des stocks des médicaments antiviraux
détenu par santé publique france ont
péri mais le contrôle des masques
chirurgicaux ont mis en évidence une non
conformité à la norme en vigueur sur un
minimum de 60% des stocks ce qui ne
permet pas de disposer des moyens de
protection contre une éventuelle
pandémie
dans ces conditions il est important
qu'une doctrine soit rapidement établie
pour que les éventuelles acquisitions de
santé soient mises en oeuvre afin de
disposer d'un stock avant le deuxième
semestre 2010 9 alors que vous étiez en
septembre 2018 ministre des solidarités
et de la santé avez vous eu connaissance
des informations contenues dans cette
lettre
monsieur bourdillon où monsieur salomon
vous ont-ils saisi voir alerté sur le
sujet du stock des médicaments
antiviraux et de masques
merci
merci madame la présidente je
commencerai par l'historique de la prise
de conscience du risque
en fait dans une nouvelle crise
sanitaire et notamment avec un agent
pathogène l'émergent on adapte à la fois
sa prise de conscience et les décisions
que l'on prend au niveau d'information
qu'on a un moment précis et donc
l'exercice
j'essayerai de faire devant vous c'est à
chaque fois de rappeler le contexte dans
lequel sont pris un certain nombre de
décisions
peut-être pour vous dire mon état
d'esprit j'ai une expérience des risques
sanitaires
de par mon métier de médecin notamment
parce que depuis des années je suis des
patients profondément immunodéprimés des
patients greffés de moi et je sais
qu'elle est la fragilité du corps humain
quand on a pas d'immunité et donc je
suis toujours en anticipation et ensuite
parce que vous le savez j'ai présidé
l'institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire
à une époque où j'ai eu à gérer la crise
de fukushima
donc voilà j'ai une certaine expérience
de l'évolution des crises sanitaires
donc j'ai eu une première alerte
totalement par hasard pendant mes
vacances de noël ou autour du 25
décembre
j'ai vu qu'un blog en anglais rapportait
des cas d'une pneumonie inexpliqué je
suis tombé dessus par hasard sur twitter
et j'ai eu le regard attiré gelé
adressée au directeur général de la
santé oms réalité l'alertent a été donné
par la chine de 31 janvier sur des
pneumonies inexpliquée et l'om est
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
fait une notification aux agences
sanitaires au réseau des agences
sanitaires le 1er janvier date à
laquelle la direction générale de la
santé ouvre ce qu'on appelle une veille
c'est à dire qu'elle va suivre ce
dossier comme toutes les agences
sanitaires du monde
mon premier peut-être nouveaux niveaux
d' alerte est je crois le autour du 11
janvier
parce que la chine annonce un premier
décès est donc on a d'une part
l'information que c'est un nouveau virus
de la famille du coronavirus et d'autre
part que ce virus pète grave puisque un
décès rapportés et donc je décide à ce
moment-là de la forme et le président de
la république et le premier ministre
qu'il existe un phénomène en chine
à l'époque de 11 janvier peut-être pour
vous rappeler le nombre de cas excusez
moi je cherche je pense qu'il y a
rapporté moins de 100 cas une
cinquantaine de cas en chine il vous
dire exactement pardon nous avons le
premier mort je cherche le nombre de cas
je ne vais pas exactement mais c'est au
tour d'une cinquantaine de cas alors je
décide d'en faire une alerte et ensuite
tout cela est suivi par le chorus qui se
met au niveau de veille de niveau 2
autour du 22 janvier pour une raison
c'est à dire que vous me demander ma
prise de conscience est en réalité la
prise de conscience évolue parce que le
22 janvier
le ms dit qu'il y à une transmission
interhumaine
et c'est là où l'on comprend que ce
n'est pas un phénomène local qui est
liée au marché aux poissons ou un
réservoir animal mais qu'à partir du
moment où il ya une transmission
interhumaine avéré à ce moment là il
peut y avoir un phénomène épidémique est
donc à partir du 22 janvier
nous avons la notion de cette
contamination interhumaine qui change
absolument le regard qu'on a sur un
phénomène qui jusqu'à présent
est localisée à one alors vous
m'interrogez sur ma première conférence
de presse en réalité le 21 janvier le
directeur général de la santé évoque
déjà cette contamination interhumaine il
commence à avoir des retours sur le fait
que l'om est ce le lendemain va déclarer
la contamination interhumaine est voyant
donc il ya un phénomène qui peut prendre
de l'ampleur du fait de cette diffusion
possible
je décide de faire une première
conférence de presse pour alerter les
médias et les français qu'il existe un
phénomène en chine et je voudrais vous
rappeler ce jour là ma prise de parole
en entier parce qu'elle a été beaucoup
d'efforts mais je me permettrai madame
la présidente de la lyre jeudi vous le
savez le 31 décembre 2019 l'organisation
mondiale de la santé a informé de
plusieurs cas de pneumonie dans la ville
de wuhan en chine je crois que c'est 27
cas le virus jusqu'ici inconnu a été
identifiée c'est un coronavirus ce type
de virus provoque chez l'homme des
maladies le plus souvent bénigne mais
certains peuvent propos provoquer des
symptômes plus sévères
nous sommes au début de l'épidémie et
nous n'avons pas la réponse à toutes les
questions qui se posent et c'est normal
la situation est très évolutive et
l'évolution des connaissances permettra
d'en savoir plus sur les modes de
transmission de ce virus
autant que son origine et donc la
transmission interhumaine
elle est affirmé par l' oms le lendemain
et jeudi le risque d'introduction en
france deux cas liés à cet épisode est
faible je rappelle que à cette date il y
a une cinquantaine de cas en chine mais
ne peut être exclu ne peut être exclue
d'autant qu'il existe des lignes
aériennes directes entre la france et la
ville de roanne des messages de
précaution à destination des voyageurs
se rendant de wuhan à paris ou retour de
one sont d'ores et déjà diffusée dans
les avions ça c'est une décision que
nous prenons le 10 janvier
quand nous savons qu'il s'agit d'un
coronavirus et voilà je parle des
mesures de gestion aux frontières
qui sont conformes recommandations de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
jeudi également que notre système de
santé est informé ce sont notamment les
messages l'alertent qui sont adressées
le 10 janvier à la fois aux ars puis aux
sociétés savantes long que 10 janvier
nous informons les samu les services
d'urgence et nous informons les stades
bêtise
le samu urgences et service de maladies
infectieuses
voilà donc et il ya un dispositif
d'information qui est mis au sein des
aéroports
aussi et dans les avions donc voila nous
de nous donnons aux professionnels de
santé des recommandations sur
l'identification des cas le repérage et
la prise en charge qu'on doit leur
fournir
donc ma conférence de presse du 21
janvier
je prends je prends la décision avant
même la confirmation officielle de l'om
est ce qu'il existe une transmission
interhumaine
je précise que ça va être évolutif si je
prends cette décision c'est parce que
j'imagine bien que ça va être évolutif
et qui va falloir raconté étape par
étape ce que nous savons à ce que nous
ne savons pas je pense être la seule
ministre de la santé européennes avoir
pris la décision de faire une conférence
de presse aussitôt à cette tête là il
n'y a pas d' alerte de l oms
il n'y a pas d' alerte spécifique
d'urgence de santé publique
internationale donc et ensuite nous
décidons d'informer les français tous
les jours soit le directeur général de
la santé sois moi-même pour faire part
de l'évolution du nombre de cas dans le
monde et des nouvelles connaissances que
nous allons acquérir sur la contagiosité
la mortalité
le mode de transmission et c'est donc
tous les jours nous faisons un point
presse c'est bien parce que j'ai une
perception qu'il se passe quelque chose
et que cette chose peut évoluer que je
décide de faire cette conférence de
presse on peut me reprocher a posteriori
d'avoir pris la parole avant n'importe
quel c'est le 21 janvier
même que l'on ms10 officiellement qu'il
ya une transmission interhumaine
avant cette période l'om est ce enfin la
chine confirme qu'il s'agit d'un
coronavirus vert avant le 10 janvier
vers le 10 janvier et l' oms dans ces
notifications parle surtout du marché
aux poissons du raid de la réserve
animale est en réalité pour moi le
tournant c'est le 22 janvier quand on
nous parle de transmission interhumaine
mais j'ai fait de ma conférence de
presse un voile assure un bon sur les
prises de conscience
ensuite le niveau d' alerte monde à cran
quand nous avons les premiers cas en
france et le premier cas en france c'est
le 24 janvier le vendredi soir à 20
heures nous avons les trois premiers cas
qui sont rapportés je fais ma conférence
de presse quotidienne et
je prend immédiatement des décisions ces
décisions elles sont multiples d'abord
je téléphone au directeur général de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
d'abord pour lui dire que nous avons les
premiers cas en france mais surtout en
europe
je n'arrive pas à la voir ce jour là je
téléphone à la commissaire européenne de
la santé stella kyriakidou ce pour lui
demander qu'elle organise une réunion
des ministres de la santé européens en
urgence pour vérifier que nous
harmonisons les pratiques
elle me dit à ce moment là que ça n'est
pas de sa responsabilité mais qu'il faut
que je demande à la présidence croate
darcis est à la présidence croate
d'organiser un conseil des ministres
j'appelle donc le ministre croate pour
demander on organise le plus rapidement
possible d'un conseil des ministres
européens
je prends des décisions de faire un état
des lieux de tous les stocks et de nos
capacités de prise en charge des malades
dans le week end qui suit cette arrivée
des premiers cas en france qui sont des
cas importés de chine
tous des gens qui étaient dans la région
de dubaï ou un one même plutôt à vos
hyman bahia et je demande qu'on me fasse
remonter par les ars l'état le nombre de
lits de réanimation le nombre de
respirateurs qu'on me fasse une remontée
de toutes les capacités de prise en
charge en termes de stocks de masques de
matériaux alex perrin ça c'est quelque
chose on n'appuie pas sur un bouton au
ministère de la santé pour savoir
combien il ya de respirateurs en france
donc les établissements publics privés
s'équipent voilà donc il faut que j'aie
une remontée de terrain
je demande immédiatement à ce que santé
publique france me fasse trois scénarios
possibles d'évolution d'épidémie et je
demande qu'ils me la fasse dans les 24
heures j'alerte évidemment délirer trois
premiers cas j'alerte le président et le
premier ministre
le premier ministre organise dans
l'urgence une réunion de ministres
le dimanche sachant qu'il ya une rime à
matignon le lendemain matin
9h avec les services et je demande
également aux structures de recherche
notamment professeur yazdan yazdanpanah
que vous connaissez de reacting de me
proposer immédiatement l'écriture d'un
protocole de recherche allaient tous les
antiviraux que nous connaissons pour que
nous soyons précis jamais d'épidémie
démarre à jour en france à proposer des
protocoles cliniques d'évaluation des
antiviraux disponibles
voilà ce que je fais dans le week-end du
24 au 25 janvier
je demande évidemment parmi cette liste
là où en sont les masques et je demande
qu'on recommande d'ailleurs des masques
à cette période là donc comme vous le
savez la commande de deux masques est
parti pour de dire une bêtise
le 30 janvier monsieur rapporteur vous
avez la parole merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre vous avez
indiqué que vous étiez impatiente de
vous retrouver devant notre commission
pour établir des faits que vous n'avez
pas pu évoqué précédemment donc nous y
voilà et nous sommes heureux de vous
entendre et de pouvoir vous posez ces
questions
d'abord de façon un peu général
j'ai lu vos déclarations multiples et
notamment celle du 17 mars dans le monde
que vous venez d'évoquer mais également
cette prise de conscience que vous nous
dites avoir eu très tôt vers la
mi-décembre 20 en prenant connaissance
de ce tweet donc avant qu'il y ait cette
alerte officiel vous nous indiquez
également bien connaître de par votre
votre profession bien sûr et nous le
mesurons et nous l'apprécions ces sujets
liés à la diffusion d'un virus et
parallèlement on a le sentiment en tout
cas j'ai le sentiment et je voulais vous
interrogé là-dessus au début de façon un
peu général que vous nous indiquez cette
prise de conscience ou de indiqué avoir
alerté dès le 11 janvier le président de
la république
d'ailleurs je vous demande sous quelle
forme et de de quelle nature le 30
janvier le premier ministre mais ona de
façon un peu global le sentiment que
malgré cette cette prise de conscience
la réaction est très lente je n'en veux
que pour preuve l'activation du plan de
pandémie qui n'intervient que le 23
février dont très tardivement pourquoi
ce délai très long
je n'en veux pour preuve également et je
pense qu on y reviendra parce que c'est
un sujet important et qui a fait débat
voire polémique sur la question des
masques vous nous le préciser à
l'instant la première commande est
passée pour 1,1 million de masques ffp2
le 30 janvier
or nous savons et nous le savons depuis
2018 et la note du comité d'experts
dirigé par le professeur ce talent de
grenoble qu'il faut dans la population
un milliard de masques 20 millions de
foyers
dotée d'une boîte de 50 masques c'est
une note que
santé publique france et son directeur
monsieur bourdillon adresse à la dgs
est-ce que vous en avez eu connaissance
alors à cette même période septembre
vous avez le retour en tout cas la dgs
transmises par santé publique france que
la plupart des masques en stock sont
périmés c'est l'analyse de centex belle
donc on a ces deux éléments sur les
stocks
vous avez la connaissance de la crise
est néanmoins vous ne commandez je
dirais que 1,1 million de masques
je rappelle que les besoins qui nous ont
été indiquées sont de 40 millions par
semaine pour les soignants et de 500
millions pour la population donc ça veut
dire qu'il n'ya quasiment très très peu
de commandes sur sur ces sujets et il
faut attendre le mois de février pour
avoir une commande plus importante 28
millions de ff et 2 le 7 février et 175
millions vous n'êtes déjà plus en
responsabilité de l'affairé 2 le 25
février
donc pourquoi cet écart important entre
la prise de conscience que vous nous
dites avoir eu et les faits le
confirment
et cette absence de réaction globale le
plan pandémie est également
la mise en oeuvre de la gestion des
stocks stratégiques que ce soit pour les
masques les respirateurs et puis pour
les tests alors je conviens que
naturellement sur les tests
l'anticipation elle pouvait pas se faire
avant bien entendu la la connaissance du
virus mais néanmoins ona on a est-ce que
sur les tests vous avez lancé des
actions précises et puis je voudrais
vous interrogez un peu aussi sur
l'anticipation de la crise donc avant
que nous ayons connaissance des
informations venues de chine
le professeur salomon il n'était pas
encore directeur général de la santé a
rédigé une note
nous avons interrogé là-dessus il était
alors conseiller à la fois de marisol
touraine et puis du candidat emmanuel
macron en disant nous ne sommes pas
prêts ne sont pas prêts à affronter une
crise sanitaire
qu'est ce qui a été fait dans cette
période de mai 2017 a fait janvier
février 2020 où vous quittez votre
ministère pour mieux préparer notre pays
à une situation de crise et de crise
grave qu'elle a été l'anticipation et
puis enfin je voudrais vous interroger
ce stade
j'aurai d'autres questions plus tard
mais sur la façon dont on a géré dont a
été géré cette cette crise le william
dab qui a été directeur général de la
santé nous a livré un sentiment que
quelque part on peut peut être partagé
en disant on n'a pas fait grand chose
entre varier sa phrase exacte était rien
ne s'est passé jusqu'au 16 mars
donc jusqu'au confinement voilà et puis
dans la gestion de cette crise qui a été
le pilote
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
c'est exactement la raison pour laquelle
je souhaitais pouvoir m'exprimer devant
cette commission
car nous n'avons pas cessé d'agir depuis
le 10 janvier date à laquelle nous avons
la connaissance qu'il s'agit de la
coronavirus leçon de crise a été remonté
niveau régulièrement mais je vais y
revenir mais c'est justement l'occasion
pour moi de vous dire à quel point nous
avons anticipé et notamment anticipé par
rapport aux alerte de niveau
international
alors peut-être vous rappeler que j'ai
quitté ministères de 15 février à
l'époque où il y avait eu 12 ko france
tous des cas importés de chine ou en
lien avec one donc il y avait eu six cas
importés de chine est un cluster le
cluster des contamines-montjoie qui
avait été totalement circonscrit et
puisque aucun cas secondaire n'est
apparue après les les cas de contaminer
mon joint donc nous étions en fait j'ai
eu à gérer le stade 1 et la dernière
semaine le stade 2 c'est à dire premier
cluster autour du 6 février de
l'épidémie alors pourquoi je vous dis
que je suis en anticipation mais je vais
vous lire le risque assessments de
l'oecd sais c'est quoi le cdc je pense
que vous savez c'est européenne control
center for control for disease control
européen
c'est une institution qui comprend enfin
plusieurs centaines de personnes en
charge d'évaluer les risques donc le 14
février le cdc fait à brice casas manne
publique
je vous lis en français même s'il est en
anglais sur la page il dit à ce stade il
existe 40 cas importés dans l'union
européenne et en angleterre
donc ça co2 au 13 février le guide le
public 14 février il dit c'est 44 cas
sont tous en lien avec one
donc ce sont que des cas importés n'y a
encore aucun cas secondaire
ok aucune épidémie
robben le cdc dit le risque pour la
capacité des systèmes de santé dans
l'union européenne qui résulteraient
d'une transmission généralisée au plus
fort de la saison grippale puisque nous
sommes en saison grippale est considéré
comme faible à modéré et le cdc rajoute
le risque associé à l'infection par le
cos vide pour la population de l'union
européenne est de l'angleterre l'uruguay
est actuellement faible
voilà l'évaluation des risques de le
céder c'est le 14 février la veille de
mon départ
trois semaines avant le 25 janvier trois
semaines avant
j'ai déjà demandé à tous les hôpitaux à
toutes les adresses de me faire remonter
tous les stocks les respirateurs les
masques notre capacité à dégager des
lits je demande trois semaines avant des
protocoles de recherche au professeur à
gaz dont pour évaluer tous les
antiviraux si jamais une épidémie arrive
je demandais scénario de violence
j'appelle mes homologues on reviendra
sur l'international donc pourquoi je
pense que j'ai anticipé parce que vous
voyez le niveau de risque le 14 février
évalué par l'instance de la commission
européenne en charge d'évaluer les
risques épidémiques
après cette décision de 25 janvier de
mettre en tension le système de santé et
d'avoir des remontées de terrain pour
savoir comment nous allons jauger
rennais éventuelle épidémie
hier je me projette toujours dans le
risque le plus grave c'est mon rôle
et c'est aussi ma pressentiment où ma
sensibilité de par mes fonctions
antérieures
eh bien je met en branle tout le système
le 25 janvier alors que l' oms a refusé
de déclarer le 22 et le 23
l'urgence de santé publique de portée
internationale c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour laquelle j'appelle tedros
le vendredi 24
est ce que je veux comprendre pourquoi
il considère que ce n'est pas une
urgence puisque mon pressentiment et que
ça pourrait l'être et la nuit urgence de
santé publique internationale de portée
internationale
elle est posée par le ms cinq jours
après le 30 janvier donc j'ai déjà mis
en place j'ai déjà interpellé des
établissements et les ars cinq jours
avant et les chercheurs et santé
publique france et j'ai commandé des
masques et j'ai demandé déjà qu'on
recommande des masques après vous me
posez la question spécifique de la
commande
oui pardon vous me posez la question du
rapport fournit à santé publique france
là évidemment
finalement vous d'imaginer les rapports
d'experts dans les agences sanitaires ne
remonte pas à la ministre ne sont pas
adressés à la mission adressée au
directeur de l'agencé sanitaire qui les
commet donc voilà je n'ai pas évidemment
d'information là dessus
en tant que ministre à la date où le
rapport est fait je n'ai pas plus
d'intérêt pour donner moi pour tel ou
tel type de réponse à un risque
sanitaire tous les risques sur une table
sont importants à prendre en compte
notamment ont 18 18 ou on est assez
inquiet du risque d'attentât chimique
vous me posez la question de savoir ce
que dit le rapport salle je pense qu'on
y reviendra peut-être je voudrais vous
dire la commande de 2 1 millions de du
30 janvier en fait en fait moi je comme
je demande qu'on recommande des masques
donc ce week-end l'un le temps que la
commande de parts elle par le trempe on
va était de quel masque parlons nous à
ce moment là nous parlons de masques
ffp2 en fait je prends la décision le 28
janvier alors qu'il n'y a pas d' urgence
de santé publique internationale de
portée internationale pendant une messe
je prends la décision de constituer un
stock d'état de masques ffp2 parce qu'il
n'en a pas vous savez que c'est la
doctrine de 2010 il n'y a pas de stock
d'état pour les masques ffp2 et je me
dis peut-être je me dis qu'il va falloir
des masques parce que je me projette
toujours dans une infection de la ram et
la doctrine de 2011 qui remet la
responsabilité des masques ffp2 aux
employeurs aux hôpitaux aux indépendants
parce qu'en réalité
dans la doctrine de 2011 c'est aux
professionnels de santé de s'équiper au
maine
je me dis mieux vous commandez démarre
sans savoir quels sont les besoins de
terrain puisque les ars ne m'ont pas
encore répondu je leur ai demandé je
fais partir le 28 janvier une demande
aux rs de me faire remonter les besoins
de terrain des établissements et des
professionnels libéraux d'ailleurs et je
me dis en attendant cette réponse
commandant des masques et faisons un
stock détail n'existe pas donc cette
commande
moi je demande qu'elle soit faite moi ce
que j'attends mon niveau c'est là comme
la création d'un stock stratégique de ma
de masques ffp2 un stock d'état de
masques ffp2 après ce sont les services
qui décide de la quantité et ensuite
nous sont remontés les besoins des ars
qui me remonte par une note du dgs le 6
février
qui nous dit en gros que le nombre de la
quantité de masques disponibles pour les
soignants très variable d'un
établissement à l'autre c'était avec
certains établissements ont des stocks
d'un mois d'autres moins d'autres plus
parce qu'en réalité ils se sont emparés
de façon variable de la doctrine de 2011
est donc à ce moment là nous faisons
partir une commande beaucoup plus
important à partir des besoins terrain
mais j'ai d'ores et déjà créé un stuff
d'état et commandé des masques ffp2
alors que ce n'est pas la responsabilité
initiale de l'état la présidente qui
était le pilote se demandait qui était
le pilote assure sur le peut-être si
vous m'autorisez ma présence sur la
question des masses dont vous nous
confirmer que à aucun moment vous n'avez
eu connaissance de la note de santé
publique france au dgs sur les besoins
en masques d'une part et d'autre part
sur le fait que le stock de masques je
parle de masques chirurgicaux était
périmé selon l'analyse du cabinet belge
centex mais ça c'était septembre 2018
la note de monsieur bourdillon à
monsieur salon donc vous n'avez jamais
eu connaissance de ces deux éléments
non c'est j'ai voulu refaire non ça
n'est pas remonté à la miss mais pour
autant depuis que j'écoute les auditions
depuis une semaine puis j'ai lu la
mission d'information j'ai essayé de
comprendre donc j'ai essayé de retourner
aux archives qu'on me fasse remonter des
notes
évidemment ce que je comprends de
l'histoire a posteriori puisque en fait
cette question spécifique ne remonte pas
à la ministre c'est que le directeur
général de la santé benoît valais avant
mon arrivée en fonction en 2017
demanda santé publique france d'évaluer
la qualité des stocks et marisol
touraine a tout à fait raison de dire
qu'il y avait 700 millions de masques
nous avons la réponse
dix-huit mois plus tard par santé
publique sens qui avait lu les stocks
qui a évalué les stocks de tous les
stocks stratégiques pas que des masques
est ce que je comprends c'est qu'en
réalité il ya énormément de choses
périmés mais pas que les masques pas que
les masques en réalité santé publique
france réalise à l'occasion de cette
demande de la dgs on peut se demander si
ça va être pu être fait avant plus vite
plutôt si les stocks avaient pu tourner
dans tous les cas la dgs réalise c'est
ce que je comprend des archives que j'ai
récupéré cette semaine
en 2018 le dgs découvre tout d'un coup
que beaucoup de choses sont périmés
qu'une ligne aile et pense qu'il ne vous
le dit pas il saisit votre cabinet à
l'époque il peut être ils décident ils
décident et c'est totalement dans son
spectre de
de reconstituer un stock décide de
reconstituer un stock et fait partir
immédiatement une commande
cette commande intervient je pense le 30
octobre je crois 2018 il envoie un
courrier mais c'est ce sont des
documents qu'on mesure qu'on remonte des
archives que j'ai demandé le 30 octobre
il nous demande effectivement à sainté
budget france de reconstituer des stocks
alors de façon probablement pluriannuel
parce qu'on reconstitue pas la totalité
des stocks péri mais j'imagine en une
fois peut-être qu'il ya des discussions
dans les services mais avec une liste
liste de produits dans lequel une ligne
dédiée
donc je suis totalement et j'assume
totalement la décision qui a été prise
par le directeur général de la santé
j'ai choisi jérôme salomon comme
directeur général de la santé de par son
expérience des crises c'est très
difficile de trouver un directeur
général de la santé c'est probablement
un des postes de direction
d'administration centrale le plus
difficile il faut être médecin il faut
connaître l'administration il faut
travailler nuit et jour
il faut être prêt à être en commission
denquête dès qu'il ya une crise
sanitaire et on est souvent voilà accusé
d'avoir fait ou mal fait c'est le poste
le plus difficile je pense le nombre de
personnes en france qui sont capables de
prendre ce poste se comptent sur les
doigts d'une main et j'ai choisi jérôme
salle au monde pas pour son expérience à
la fois en santé publique en
infectiologie parce qu'il avait géré
plusieurs crises sanitaires notamment la
grippe aviaire dont cabinet de kouchner
et bola au cabinet de marisol touraine
et c'est une porte pour cette expérience
là que je vous ai demandé de me
rejoindre la direction générale de la
santé et donc je lui fais totalement
confiance et j'assume totalement des
décisions qu'il prend nous allons passer
aux questions des parlementaires
en terre avec tout d'abord dans l'ordre
des groupes issus à battre pour les
républicains
je sais que vous avez de la sincérité en
vous simplement je voudrais qu'on aille
jusqu'au bout de cette sincérité 1 à la
ministre et surtout qu'on comprenne un
certain nombre de choses en fait le
drame c'est que vous avez la bonne
intuition mais que la mise en oeuvre est
calamiteuse et il nous faut comprendre
pourquoi cette mise en oeuvre est
calamiteuse nous dit j'assume la
décision de commandes sur les masques
mais dans le même temps vous dites mais
je suis pas informé de cette décision et
c'est un peu paradoxal d'assumer une
décision sur lequel on n'est pas informé
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas informée à ce
moment là et qu'est ce qui fait que
finalement dans votre mécanisme d'
alerte si vous étiez inquiète depuis
quelques temps déjà dans les commandes
de masques que vous faites
finalement on se contente du minimum
alors certes vous faites vous le dites
une commande de 1 million notamment sur
les ffp2 mais simplement ce que
j'aimerais comprendre c'est pourquoi
c'est un million vous dit c'est pas moi
en tant que ministre qui détermine la
quantité mais on le sait bien que la
quantité
alain impacte forcément sur la
protection de la population en tant que
telle et donc au moins est ce que là
dessus
vous avez demandé des précisions est ce
que il ya des chiffres qui ont tourné
est ce qu un moment donné c'était juste
un million ou est ce qu'il ya eu des
arbitrages à faire entre différentes
capacités ou pas on a besoin de
comprendre cet écart là parce que là
dessus il ya un besoin de clarification
merci monsieur abad monsieur le député
par dont il est fou de il faut de dire
que mon intuition n'a pas été suivi par
les services
c'est absolument faux c'est de ça dont
je viens vous parler aujourd'hui ce que
nous avons mis en place au ministère de
la santé depuis le 10 janvier est sans
commune mesure
en tous les cas en termes d'anticipation
avec ce que j'ai vu notamment dans les
autres pays et j'y reviendrai
l'intuition
elle se traduit par un travail quotidien
avec le dg c'est à dire qu'à partir du
10 janvier le directeur général de la
santé on en voit tous les matins à 8h
parfois même à cette heure un point
complet de la situation et nous
échangeons soit par texto soit elle
vient dans mon
euros il n'y a pas un jour depuis le 10
janvier où je n'ai pas plusieurs
réunions par texto par mail ou physique
avec le directeur gmt nous travaillons
main dans la main de la même façon
dès que j'alerte le premier ministre sur
les premiers cas français et qu'il faut
à ce moment-là mettre en tension système
de santé français
une réunion de ministres la première
réunion de ministres est décidé à
matignon dans le week-end un dimanche
donc l'intuition elle est totalement
partagé avec le directeur général de la
santé sincèrement je pourrais vous lire
la totalité des décisions que nous
prenons jour après jour on m'a dit que
ça ne se fait pas de prendre la parole
pendant trois quarts d'heure dans une
commission d'un club je veux bien le
faire devant je veux bien faire devant
vous il n'y a pas une journée où ne
prenons pas des décisions pas une
journée où nous n'avons pas anticipé
toujours par rapport à l' oms l ecdc
nous sommes toujours en avance par
rapport aux décisions internationales
donc en aucun cas je peux vous dire qu
en aucun cas je peux laisser dire que le
ministère de la santé a été lent je peux
vous donner non alors les commandes les
commandes elles viennent à l'esprit
quand on comprend qu'il ya un risque
épidémique et le risque épidémique
il n'existe que lorsqu'il ya une
transmission interhumaine tant que c'est
un réservoir animal
awan fusée mois dans l'esprit de l'om
mais c'est dans l'esprit de tout le
monde c'est une épidémie où il passe
quelque chose
awan ou à dubaï en fait on comprend tout
d'un coup qui se passe quelque chose de
grave
et c'est là on met tout en tension entre
le 22 et le 24 janvier le 22
transmission interhumaine le 23 des
autorités chinoises ferme la ville de
one la mettre sous cloche
on comprend qu'il met tout le monde en
quarantaine ce qui est très bizarre
d'ailleurs par rapport au nombre de cas
affiché
le 24 nous avons les trois premiers cas
français importés je vais vous faire
part de pourquoi nous avons été alertés
donc trois premiers le cas français et
nous avons le 24 l'information que les
origines chinoises ont construire un
hôpital de milly a one c'est discordants
par rapport aux 50 cas et et cette
discordance nous la percevons temps nous
analysons le premier cas français le cas
de bordeaux iv bordeaux c'est un
monsieur marchand de vin qui a été en
chine
travailler et qui arrive de shanghai
mais il est passé à one deux jours vers
le 13 14 janvier excusez moi ce sont mes
souvenirs ce sont des souvenirs mais
j'ai pas c'est peut-être le 12 et être
que 14 enfin c'est au tour du 12 13
janvier il passa one au tour du doubs
sera chanté janvier pour faire une
négociation avec des chaussures la vente
de vin il ne va pas au marché aux
poissons
à l'époque il ya moins de 50 cas à one
qui est une agglomération de 12 millions
d'habitants et on se dit comment un
homme qui a passé deux jours dans une
ville de 12 millions d'habitants où il
ya 50 cas de pneumonie alors qu'il n'a
pas été dans le lieu d'où vient la
pneumonie le marché aux poissons
comment se fait il qu'il ait attrapé
cette maladie et à ce moment là c'est là
mon niveau
en fait deux très occupation monte d'un
cran et que le 25 le 25 janvier c'est à
dire le lendemain des premiers cas
français de lendemain du premier cas
analysés et c'est sur cette intuition là
qu'il se passe quelque chose mais que
c'est paco concordant avec ce que nous
disent les autorités chinoises et même
l'appréciation générale je met en branle
tout le système sanitaire français
je passe commande deux protocoles je
demande qu'on fait une remontée sur le
nombre de respirateurs le nombre
d'équipements le monde le nom
de l'hydre et un notre capacité de lits
je demandais scénario de dangerosité à
santé publique france et je demande une
réunion chez le premier nice qui a lieu
le jour même
vous ne pouvez pas dire que je n'ai pas
anticiper et je ne serai pas dire que
les services montrent antilles c'est ce
qu'a fait le directeur général de la
santé depuis le 10 janvier est
incommensurable je peux vous dire
combien il ya eu une alerte aux
professionnels de santé elles ont
commencé le 10 janvier aux
professionnels libéraux
passionnément aux ars une 14 janvier aux
donc on a mis en tension ce système ce
système de soins il est il a tenu il a
tenu et merci aux soignants mais merci
aussi au sein de crise parce que c'est
pas rien de monter en puissance en
double en nombre de lits de réanimation
dans un pays comme le nôtre en l'espace
de quelques jours
je n'étais plus là mais cette
préparation elle s'est concrétisée par
des commandes
vous me dites que les commandes sont
tardives je demande qu'on passe commande
le lendemain non mais mais mais mais il
n'y a pas d' alerte internationale c'est
juste sur mon intuition ya pas d'aller y
a pas du sp pays
il n'y a pas d' alerte de l oms le ms a
refusé de déclarer l'urgence sanitaire
de portée internationale je vous ai lu
le risque à ces semaines de le cdc du 14
février
ce que je fais là c'est trois semaines
avant monsieur haddad
je demande que les ars me remonte tout
le capacitaire de prise en charge d'une
épidémie en france
alors oui je fais une commande
je ne sais pas en fait je ne sais pas
cette date la fille les hôpitaux ont
bien pris en compte la doctrine
dominante je n'en sais rien et donc la
note de retour des ars arrive à la dgs
le 6 février et le 7 février
je lance des commandes mais pas que des
masques de sur blues
sur chaussures de lunettes de en fait
parce que on est aujourd'hui totalement
focalisés sur les masques et je le
comprends parce que c'est ce qui a
manqué à un moment donné je le comprends
mais aurait été dans ma préparation je
prépare tout en même temps je suis je
prépare les lits de réanimation je
prépare le nombre de respirateurs je
m'interroge
par exemple le excusez moi je vais vous
donner une décision qui est prise c'est
de la retrouver
tellement de notes lorsque nous
commandons je cherche un des ciments
comprenons oui c'est le cde 7 février je
crois que c'est le 7 février nous
prenons la décision fusée mans à la fin
tu désolé voilà le 6 février
donc la nôtre montrent déjà des ars avec
les besoins des hôpitaux et ce qu'ils
sont capables de faire
le 7 février je donne nous donnons
l'accord à la dgs pour commander des
masques des lunettes des gants des
chaussures des charlotte dussault lité
hydroalcoolique
nous donnons notre accord pour que tous
ses stocks
donc c'est stop d'état ffp2 qui n'existe
pas donc nous le creu nous le
constituant et nous a donné notre accord
pour que c'est des kits soient
distribués aux médecins et aux
infirmiers aux pharmaciens libéraux nous
donnons notre accord pour une délivrance
de tous ses produits aux établissements
santé aux ehpad pour un mois en termes
de stocks d'amore ce alors que je vous
rappelle que la doctrine veut que ce
soit chaque établissement qui sont en
responsabilité sur ces objets de 13 en
charge
c'est bien ça le problème c'est qu'en
réalité il n'y a pas de stock d'état
pour ces produits là ces produits là
c'est à la charge des établissements et
nous réalisons avec la note du dg
du 6 février thé et à distance en sont
emparés de façon variable et que les
libéraux encore moi c'est un fait mais
c'est quelque chose que nous découvrons
et donc nous donnons notre accord pour
que ce soit délivrée aux établissements
aux ehpad aux professionnels libéraux
et je vous rappelle que nous donnons cet
accord le 7 février
c'est à dire alors que la pandémie est
déclaré quand même le 11 mars
cinq semaines après vous pouvez pas dire
qu'on n'a pas été réactif
merci mais ça n'arrive pas c'est une je
vais vous demander de ne pas faire ne
pas installer des noms mais je comprends
bien alors il y avait la dernière
question qui était plus politique sur
votre décision de quitter le
gouvernement
parce que là j'ai laissé sur la gestion
du stock je pense que c'est très
important qu'on ait ces précisions
maintenant voilà madame la ministre vous
avez encore une question de se pavaner
ensuite on passe aux autres questions
un pardon excusez moi monsieur dame
alors j'ai commandé tout ça nous sommes
le 7 détaillé
donc tout est parti le pardon je j'ai
commandé après vous le savez je pense
que c'est une découverte de tous les
pays du monde on découvre quelque part
que ces produits là ils sont fabriqués
en chine et que la tension est déjà
extrême au moment de la commande par
mais la commande vous pouvez pas dire
qu'elle ait pas été précoce le 14
février
je vous lis je vous ai lui le risque à
ces semaines de la cdc il n'y a pas
d'épidémie en europe il ya 44 cas en
europe l'écart en france ont été
circonscrits donc c'est la technique
coréenne
donc on définit un cas on isole on trace
les contacts ou testent les contacts et
les 200 enfants de l'école des
contamines-montjoie on les met en
quarantaine et voilà le cluster des
contamines-montjoie est totalement
je vais pas de cas secondaires je quitte
le ministère
le 15 il n'y a pas eu de cas nouveaux
depuis neuf jours aucun cas nouveau en
france
le contexte vous le savez monsieur aba'a
des politiques et particuliers
république en marche n'a plus de
candidat à la mairie de paris
moi j'estime que j'ai fait mon travail
de préparation du système de santé sur
14 janvier d'ailleurs je demande à
toutes les adresses de mettre en place
le plan orsec rêve pour le risque
épidémique dans toutes les régions
c'est l'équivalent du plan orsec donc il
est activé dans toutes les régions le 14
février quand je pars ça veut dire la
mise en tension du système ça veut dire
la capacité à dégager des lits à annuler
des ddd soins programmés ça veut dire
les commandes qui sont passés par là
tout le système est mis en préparation
et en tension je quitte le ministère
avec le sentiment que j'ai fait la bonne
préparation
pardon je quitte le ministère je donne
ma démission le dimanche 16 excusez moi
et je le jeu quitte le ministère parce
qu'il ya un contexte politique et que je
suis comme vous je pense qu'il faut un
moment se présenter devant les électeurs
et j'ai aussi le sentiment que un maire
parce que j'espère être mère a un rôle
majeur à jouer dans les crises on l'a vu
les collectivités locales
on joue un rôle majeur et donc j'estime
avoir préparé le système de santé et
d'être maintenant en capacité de le
faire comme mena l'histoire a montré que
ça ne s'est pas passé simplement madame
la ministre très brièvement dans la
prolongation de la question ne soit bon
vous nous parler de la période de
janvier mais je reviendrai sur ma
question tout à l'heure sur les trois
ans précédant parce que vous nous dites
on est dépourvu de stocks stratégiques
de masques de blues que vous commandez
d'ailleurs en quelque
brrr si vous pouvez nous l'indiqué mais
pourquoi ces commandes puisque gouverner
c'est prévoir c'est pas moi qui l'ait
dit il y avait peu connaissaient pas ce
virus mais il y avait d'autres risques
potentiels qu'ils pouvaient frapper
notre pays est d'ailleurs le professeur
salomon l'avait dit dès 2016 pourquoi
ses stocks stratégiques pendant trois
ans ne sont pas constitués donc c'est
une aucune responsabilité de l'agent
santé publique france que de vérifier
d'acheter contrôler et gérer les stocks
stratégiques de l'état c'est sa mission
la mauvaise surprise est en octobre 2018
c'est quelque chose que je reconstitue
je le redis ça n'est pas ça n'arrive pas
à la miss et pour autant j'assume
parfaitement ce qui a été fait les
agences nous nous déchirons de façon
très régulière
d'abord moi je j'ai un store dès que je
suis ministre comité de direction avec
tous mes directeurs d'administration
centrale tous les lundis matin au
ministère donc on échange sur les
problèmes de la semaine le directeur
général de la santé anime le comité des
agents ce qu'on appelle le casa tous les
mois et de temps en temps c'est même la
ministre qui préside le kazan il y à une
réunion de sécurité sanitaire tous les
mercredis tous les mercredis au nissan
la santé où remontent toutes les alertes
sanitaires dans lequel sont présents
toutes les directions d'administration
sans crainte centrales y compris
l'alimentation la défense nationale le
enfin donc c'est une réunion très
importante où on remonte toutes les
alertes sanitaires toutes les agences
sont représentées notamment santé
publique france dans cette réunion de
sécurité sanitaire siège mon cabinet
donc il n'y a pas eu de remontées
d'alertés à ce niveau de la réunion de
sécurité sanitaire par une agence le
voisin mais pourtant il ya eu vous nous
dites ya des réunions chaque mois chaque
semaine avec les directeurs et sur un
sujet aussi essentiel jamais au cours
d'une de ces réunions est évoqué le fait
qu'on n'a plus de stocks stratégiques de
tous les produits et vous le découvrez
en janvier 2020 ce que vous nous dites à
ma connaissance
merci madame la ministre vous nous avez
dit à plusieurs reprises que vous étiez
parti avec le sentiment d'avoir bien
préparé notre système de santé
affronter cette crise est au fond cette
préparation
c'est votre mission votre responsabilité
dès le premier jour de votre prise de
fonction comme ministre de la santé
vous avez également dit que à chaque
fois vous projeter dans le risque le
plus grave est donc j'imagine dans la
préparation la plus complète à la
gestion d'une crise qu'elles soient
sanitaire nucléaire ou qu'il s'agisse
d'un attentat
vous avez signé vous même un contrat
d'objectifs et de performance avec santé
publique france dont vous tirez la
conclusion sur la base de ce que vous
nous avez lu que je veux aussi sur les
yeux qu' il appartient à santé publique
france 2 déterminer le volume nécessaire
de stocks stratégiques et que ce n'est
pas une compétence du ministère de la
santé mais vous avez dit une chose qui
paraît de points nul à un peu
contradictoire nous avait dit j'assume
les décisions prises par mon directeur
général de la santé au fond de détruire
600 millions de masques qui étaient
périmés mais donnant reconstituer que 50
millions + 50 millions donc je voudrais
savoir qui a véritablement cette
compétence si j'en crois le courrier de
monsieur bourdillon du 26 septembre 2018
qui répond à une sollicitation du
directeur général de la santé il répond
à cette sollicitation en concluant et
vous avez évoqué l'état des stocks
dans ces conditions il est important
qu'une doctrine soit rapidement établie
par vos services
ceux de votre directeur général et série
c'est-à-dire les vôtres pour que les
éventuelles acquisitions de produits de
santé soient mises en oeuvre afin de
disposer d'un stock avant le deuxième
semestre 2010 9 et ce qui est évoqué
pour le 2 second semestre 2010 9
c'est sur la base du rapport du
professeur ce talent c'est à dire
s'agissant notamment des masques puisque
on a beaucoup parlé chirurgicaux 1
milliard un milliard de masques
vous avez dit assumer la décision de
votre ds et ce qu'elle vous paraissait
être la bonne et est ce que vous
considérez ou commencement de la crise
que les 117 millions de masques
chirurgicaux
c'est le bon niveau de stock pour
affronter la pandémie à venir et du coup
est ce que vous pensez finalement qu'il
est inutile de reconstituer les stocks
stratégiques tel qu'il était demandé
qu'il le soit dès 2018 et là il me
paraît quand même y avoir une zone dont
sur qui fait quoi et même si tous ne
remonte pas à la munition convertie
beaucoup de choses on monte à son
cabinet je sais que les cabinets ont été
réduits dans leur périmètre et qu' ils
sont les collaborateurs sont moins
nombreux qu'avant ce qui fait je termine
est-ce qu'il y en ait qu'une seule
société sur contre le président thein
toujours ans pas une raison comme ça je
je je je t'aime je termine je termine là
j'ai perdu le fil de madame la
présidente
alors je voudrais juste pour une
question sur santé publique lance donc
qui qui fait quoi vous avait autorité
sur l'un et sur l'autre voulait réunir
régulièrement le 2 le dgs a quasi statut
de collaborateur de cabinet non la
nouvelle organisation de la république
telle qu'elle fonctionne d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que vous le voyez aussi
souvent et puis dernière question et je
termine à la présidente premier pourquoi
n'avons pas eu à nous n'avons nous pas
eu de président de santé publique france
entre juin 2009 et décembre 2010 9 la
nouvelle présidente finalement et ont
peu d'apprentissage de ses fonctions ou
non se déclenche la crise merci les
questions sont nombreuses
je vais peut-être commencer par la
dernière il est de plus en plus
difficile de trouver
des directeurs d'achat ça n'est pas un
faute de candidat mais il faut pour des
agences de ce niveau l'an un très bon
niveau scientifique et souvent des
scientifiques ne souhaite pas s'engager
dans des postes très administratif ils
préfèrent faire leurs recherches leurs
travaux donc c'est très difficile et
madame geneviève chaîne avait d'ailleurs
refusé une première fois avant
d'accepter
il faut ensuite s'assurer qu'il n'y a
aucun conflit d'intérêts industriels ce
qui est pour des médecins quand vous
avez besoin de trouver un directeur
d'agencé sanitaire qui un médecin
professeur d'université
souvent les travaux avec l'industrie
font qu'en fait ça n'est pas compatible
en réalité le pool des personnes en
capacité de reprendre des agences
sanitaires aujourd'hui est en train de
se réduire
oui ça scientifique mais depuis un an
nous cherchons non mais j'avais
rencontré beaucoup de gens le problème
c'est que soit il n'avait pas la
compétence nécessaire soit il ne le
souhaitait pas
et j'ai même été chercher à l'étranger
des suisses et des belges qui parlaient
français parce que c'est compliqué donc
c'est très difficile je ne pense pas
qu'à l'avenir ce sera plus facile
je ne parle même pas d'un directeur
général de la santé si vous voyez ce que
je veux dire donc en réalité je leur dis
ça se compte sur les doigts d'une main
des gens qui ont la compétence la
connaissance administratif qui savent
faire du management gérer et qui sont
absolument sans liens d'intérêts jamais
pour être voilà donc ça mais on a eu un
mal fou j'ai rencontré beaucoup de gens
mais nous n'avons pas trouvé
ensuite pour ce qui est des stocks ce
qui est demandé aux agences à l'état de
décider mais c'est de proposer des
doctrines et des scénarios des scénarios
normalement une agence doit vous
proposer en disant voilà je vous propose
ça ça et ça et le ministère est là pour
décider et ce qu'on demande à sainté
public france en réalité dans le kop je
reviens au kop parce que ces sont les
lignes directrices c'est d'éclairer les
décisions futures des autorités
sanitaires en mobilisant de l' expertise
sur l'adéquation optimale aux besoins
des différents types de stocks
stratégiques dans réalité c'est
exactement ça on leur demande de faire
des groupes de travail de travailler
avec les autres agences puisqu'en
réalité chaque stock est aussi les
doctrines de gestion des stocks ne
dépende peuvent dépendre aussi d'autres
agences comme l'irsn l'asn
l'ineris landes c'est cela nsn pour les
produits de santé donc on était il faut
agréger une expertise autour de chaque
produit pour déterminer quel est le
besoin
comment il se gère et c'est sain c'est
la mission de l'eprus qui est rentré
dans santé publique france donc j'en
reviens à 7
cette découverte d' octobre 2018
je rappelle quand même parce que je
crois que c'est important parce que je
crois que c'est important pour la
représentation nationale de savoir que
dans la très grande majorité des pays il
n'y a pas de stock d'état et le rapport
de monsieur ce talent chez le tableau de
stock d'état des stocks stratégiques
dans les différents pays du monde canada
usa royaume-uni allemagne suisse et en
fait quand on revient les stocks
stratégiques dans ces pays-là soignant
n'a pas du tout faire chaque
établissement de santé se débrouille
soit quand il y en a il est bien
inférieur au nôtre par exemple stocks
stratégiques
aujourd'hui des des masques donc sur le
canada n'en a pas sur les us 1 leurs
stocks stratégiques et de 37 millions en
masquer les usa le royaume uni en a 350
millions c'est leur base l'allemagne a
de stockage centralisé la suisse
obligation d'avoir des réserves de trois
mois dans les établissements sas je
pense que c'est une bonne leçon
voilà avec aussi une obligation pour la
population d'avoir une réserve
on voit bien que chaque pays a des
doctrines différentes mais en réalité en
termes de stocks d'état en dehors des
royaume uni qui a 350 millions
les autres pays n'ont pas monsieur
lagarde pour lui dit
merci madame la mise beaucoup de respect
pour vous mais j'ai du mal à vous suivre
là vous venez nous parler des obstinés à
l'étranger mais ça ne concerne pas parce
que la doctrine française c'était
d'avoir un milliard de masques et on les
avait pas et vous nous dites toutes les
réunions avec votre cabinet ont eu lieu
avec les agences etc
mais jusqu'en janvier 2020 vous n'avez
pas connaissance de l'absence de ce
stock qui pourtant est dans la doctrine
française pas au canada en angleterre ou
ailleurs dans la doctrine française
on apprend dans un article du monde que
vous avez nommés un jeune généraliste
qui officiait dans un bidasse de 50
habitants de 500 habitants dans la marne
chez dow berton comme conseiller
technique chargé de la sécurité
sanitaire j'imagine qu'ils participaient
à ces réunions
est ce qu'il a fait son travail est ce
qui vous a alerté est-ce qu'il en avait
la compétence le monde affirmant c'est
le monde qu'il n'avait pas de formation
en la matière vous nous dites on a
beaucoup anticipé on comprend mal alors
pourquoi on a manqué de respirateurs de
masse de surdose de sédatifs et pourquoi
on a proportionnellement de pays
comparables
quatre fois plus de morts en france
qu'en allemagne pardon mais les
autorités politiques quand elle tardait
à réagir
est ce qu'elles ont surveillé ce qu'ils
avaient l'obligation de constituer des
stocks un préfet de région nous a
répondu non et si notre système de santé
finalement n'est pas excessivement
centralisé donc trop long à réagir
deuxième chose on vient sur les masques
on sait d'après ce que je comprends on
sait qu'il ya 600 millions de masques
inutilisable au moment où le 22 janvier
vont nous dit on change d'attitude on se
rend compte qu'il ya quelque chose mon
intuition est juste votre dgsn en ayant
commandé que 100 millions j'imagine
qu'ils vous le dis donc on a un déficit
de potentiel de protection et je parle
même du mot de la protection de la
population je parle pas des masques ffp2
que vous avez commandé
je pars dff p1 pour la population
française pour respecter notre routine
mais monsieur salomon nous explique
qu'il voulait se tourner vers un stock
tournant et donc qu'il reconstituer
progressivement les choses et pas en une
année pas en une fois
je voudrais savoir puisque c'était sous
votre ministère conclut quand ont eu
lieu les réunions au ministère de la
santé au cours duquel on a pris ces
décisions
est ce qu'il ya des comptes rendus de
ces qu'ils étaient les participants et
aux fonds assumez vous n'avez vous
d'avoir pris le risque d'avoir un stock
tournant et 2d de laisser la france et
des français dépourvus pendant trois
quatre cinq ans le temps de racheter le
nombre de masques manque de chance c'est
là qui est arrivé la plante d'amis enfin
dernière question
monsieur moussa
ancien directeur général de la santé
nous a fait part de son point de vue de
la préparation de la france face à une
pandémie
normalement depuis 2005 on savait qu'il
y avait un risque
on souhaitait s'y entraîner est-ce que
sous votre ministère 2017 2018 2019
il y a eu des exercices de type biotox
pirates au dessous des exercices
pandémique
en avez vous eu le compte-rendu quête de
sons en avez-vous tiré
merci monsieur lagarde
bon pas dans monsieur le président je
suis désolé j'ai perdu mes réflexes
antérieures bon beaucoup de beaucoup de
questions la ministre
je le répète un n'a pas plus
connaissance du niveau nécessaire au
masque de niveau nécessaire en comprimés
diodes que deux niveaux en comprimés
d'antiviraux que d'antidote de gaz sarin
ou de gaz neurotoxique de nécessité sur
blues de protection contre ebola ou
n'avoir santé publique france gère des
dizaines de produits tout aussi
important excusez moi on aurait une
épidémie d'ebola aujourd'hui on se
poserait la question des gants on se
poserait pas la question des masques on
aurait on aurait une épidémie houdoud et
ou des tenues blanches on aurait
aujourd'hui un attentat avec un gaz
neurotoxique on se posait la question de
savoir s'ils en avaient assez au bon
endroit toc en réalité je n'ai pas à
savoir la quantité ni disponible ni
nécessaire des dizaines voire centaines
de produits gérés en réponse aux risques
sanitaires parce que ils sont
extrêmement nombreux je comprends qu'à
posteriori par rapport à une crise où on
est maintenant tout se focaliser sur la
question des masses qu'on dise ça n'est
pas possible enfin si l'épidémie avait
été d'un autre type c'est d'ailleurs
ebola n'est pas des masses qu'il faut et
si et non mais tout est prévu en réalité
tout doit être prévu et donc tout doit
être gérée de façon équivalente il ya un
an terme de d'attention portée le
directeur général de l'attenté porte la
même attention à la totalité des
produits parce que les récompenses et
nombreux
donc voilà les miss n'a pas connaître de
la totalité des produits en stock à
santé publique france même rappeler
qu'il ya trente-huit mille palette de
stockage à santé publique france ça
n'est pas en réalité ce que je dois
m'assurer sais quelle chaîne de
commandement et qu'il ya des gens en
charge et que les doctrines sont publiés
sage les faits il ya une chaîne de
commandement c'est la dgs santé publique
france il ya une doctrine c'est le kop
le kop
c'est la doctrine que je donne à santé
du français c'est leur lettre de mission
voilà ce qu'il doit faire ils doivent
proposer des scénarios travailler avec
des experts faire tourner les stocks
gérés les commandes contrôler si le kop
alors vous me dites il ya quatre fois
plus de morts en allemagne avant
france-canada pardon je ne sais pas
répondre à cette question
comme beaucoup des comme beaucoup
d'experts d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
répond il ya plein de raisons qui
peuvent expliquer la différence
ça n'est pas forcément une impréparation
d'un système de santé le système de
santé parce qu'on a parlé des tests
audard j'ai oublié de vous répondre
parce que l'état sont déjà déployés
extrêmement vite
ça peut être la façon dont l'épidémie
démarre tout bêtement je pense mais je
n'étais plus en fonction donc là c'est
probablement un sentiment que j'exclus
qui est un sentiment de médecins je
pense que le fait qu'on ait eue mulhouse
avec un départ face ont fusé dans plein
d'endroits de plaine poster réalité
affecte le système a été débordé
extrêmement vite
l'allemagne n'a pas eu l'équivalent
l'italie plutôt autour de milan italie a
été débordé est ce que ces deux fameux
match de foot je n'en sais rien je
suivais la presse à cette époque là
j'étais en campagne je suivais la presse
donc je ne peux pas je n'avais pas les
donner mais on voit bien que d'un pays à
l'autre
la tension sur le système de santé ou la
mortalité peut être différent on est
quand même face à une épidémie qui a
fait cinq cent mille morts cinq cent
mille ans donc et on voit bien que des
pays qui s'en sortait bien jusqu'à
présent commence à avoir des difficultés
je pense à la suède l'allemagne 2 qui
n'avait pas vraiment confiné des villas
confiné une ville de je crois la semaine
dernière deux cent mille habitants parce
qu'ils ont un démarrage dans un abattoir
donc on voit bien que la façon dont ça
démarre en fait peut amener à ce que le
système soit en tension plus ou moins
importantes
un endroit donné et de façon plus ou
moins rapide
après il peut y avoir je n'en sais rien
non plus je ne suis pas une spécialiste
virologue il peut y avoir des mutations
du virus qui le rend plus ou moins
agressif ou pathogènes dans certaines
régions du monde mais ça c'est je pense
ce scientifique qui nous donneront cette
réponse là il peut y avoir aussi
génétique des populations qui fait
qu'une population est plus ou moins
susceptibles à un virus qu'une autre et
ça aussi c'est le temps qui nous donnera
l'information mais de tout dit de tout
mettre sur la différence entre les pays
sur la non préparation d'un système de
santé m me paraît être un raccourci
puisque je le dis j'ai anticipé avant
les alertes de l' oms a vendu ces décès
sur les tests nous avons réussi je crois
nous sommes le premier pays en europe à
avoir mis en place des tests dès que la
séquence du virus a été publiée par les
chinois jouent trois autour du 10
janvier le centre national de référence
des coronavirus à pasteur a essayé de
produire la teste il a mis je crois une
dizaine de jours pour le produire
lorsque nous avons repéré les premiers
malades le 24 février
donc les tests étaient déjà disponibles
à paris à lyon dans des hôpitaux de
référence capable de prendre en charge
des malades et nous avons le lendemain
le 25
excusez moi le 25 janvier une
déclaration de le céder c'est quand même
plus aisément je vais vous la retrouver
je vais le cdc 25 janvier donc après les
trois premiers cas le cdc félicite la
france sur ses capacités dé cette
détection ils disent exactement deux
femmes vivent quelque chose donc je pars
je veux le dire en français le fait que
ces cas ont été identifiés prouve que la
détection et la confirmation de ce
nouveau virus fonctionne en france
montrant à haut degré de préparation
pour prévenir et contrôler et de
possible infection aux convives 19
voici ce que ti le cdc le 25 janvier moi
je veux bien qu'on soit les derniers de
la classe
mais c'est une instance auto européenne
de la commission européenne mais
simplement merci madame la présidente
peut-être une précision sur sur ces
points deux précisions
une dans la prolongation de ce que
disait boris vallot tout à l'heure cent
mille sur les masses pour terminer enfin
tout cas de mon côté 100 millions de
masques
c'est ce qu'il y avait au début 2020
madame chen dit un peu moins de 100
millions monsieur salomon 10 117
est ce que ça vous paraît conforme à la
doctrine est ce que c'était pour vous un
nombre suffisant alors que pour notre
part on a toujours un milliard de
masques depuis 2011 dans la doctrine et
sur les tests le professeur delfraissy
alors qu'ils avaient raison de rendre
hommage à la capacité de notre système
de recherche à produire très vite un
test en quelques jours mais la question
c'est que ce test une fois que les
chercheurs l'ont trouvé il m'est très
longtemps à se diffuser
pour le grand public puisque le
professeur delfraissy souligne plus tard
en disant notre problème a été que début
mars 11 et 3000 thèse par jour là où
l'allemagne en faisait cinquante mille
donc pourquoi pas on a été très vite et
vous avez raison sur la capacité de
recherche pourquoi on n'arrive pas à le
mettre en place sur le grand public
blocage absence de recours au secteur
privé des laboratoires publics par pas
mobilisés c'est un peu là la question
c'est pas à mettre en doute on sait
qu'on a des chercheurs de grand talent
et l'on démonte
c'est mais pourquoi le système est ce qu
est ce que c'est la cause est ce que le
système administratif à une inertie qui
permet pas par rapport au succès de la
recherche à le diffuser sur le terrain
très vite comme le fait l'allemagne est
l'un des et l'institut robert koch
alors moi je peux répondre de la période
où j'étais en fonction donc jusqu'au 16
février
mon objectif à partir du moment le test
est mis en place par l'institut pasteur
c'est de les déployer en urgence dans
les hôpitaux avec des services de
référence puisque je vous rappelle qu'à
l'époque la doctrine
enfin la doctrine là où nous en étions
en janvier c'est une épidémie en chine
et on est au stade 1 notre objectif
c'est d'empêcher l'entrée dans
territoire et s'il y entrer dans le
territoire
c'est d'endiguer la donc à dos traîné la
doctrine coréenne
c'est à dire il faut repérer les cas le
plus vite possible pour pouvoir suivre
les contacts pour repérer les cas il
faut être capable de faire le diagnostic
est donc d'avant la teste donc ce que je
demande
dès début janvier c'est qu' aucun malade
avec un syndrome grippal venant de wilde
puis dubaï de one puis de dubaï n'a y
voir son médecin généraliste ou
aïe aux urgences là les annonces à la
télé dans les médias c'est vous appeler
le 15 d'ailleurs on renforce les centres
15 c est donc l'idée c'est que dès qu'il
ya une suspicion une définition de cas
c'est quelqu'un qui revient de chine de
cette région et progressivement on
élargira la chine entière et bien s'il a
des symptômes grippaux
il doit appeler le 15 et allez dans un
hôpital où il peut être pris en charge
de l'urgence c'est que les hôpitaux et
des tests pour repérer les cas c'est ça
l'urgence au moment - je suis en
fonction il faut qu'on soit capable de
repérer les cas pour isoler les contacts
donc progressivement déploient les tests
dans tous les hôpitaux dans lequel on
appelle ça des esf dans tous les
hôpitaux dans lequel il ya des services
de référence en charge de prendre les
malades à haut risque d'infection
et donc quand je suis parti
l'objectif c'était que tous les hôpitaux
français est accès aux tests
à l'époque on était sûr quelques
dizaines de suspicion de cartes par jour
donc c'était des gens qui arrivait de
chine et qui se présentait au centre 15
quillan et le centre 15 l'amener à
l'hôpital pour faire des tests et à
l'époque on faisait quelques dizaines de
tests par jour pour éliminer de virus et
à l'époque où je suis parti je rappelle
qu'il y avait eu douze cas donc on était
sur des dizaines de tests par jour pour
autant j'avais anticipé le besoin de
faire plus de tests et quand je vais été
rendu à l'hôpital bichat
pour rencontrer l'équipe qui avait pris
en charge un des premiers malades
je me suis rendu à bichat le 30 juin
j'ai visité le laboratoire qui faisaient
des tests
je me suis rendu compte que le
laboratoire qui faisaient des tests
c'était un laboratoire p3 c'est à dire
un laboratoire à haut niveau de sécurité
c'est un tout petit laboratoire où il ya
très peu de machines et donc quand j'ai
réalisé que c'était dans un b3 je me
suis dit et j'ai demandé au directeur
général de la santé une saisine est
parti dès le lendemain
est-ce qu'on peut pas dégrader entre
guillemets descendre le niveau
d'exigence pour faire les tests pour
pouvoir faire le test pendant 1 p 3
et dans un pays deux parce que sinon il
n'y a pas d autre des trois dans tous
les hôpitaux de france et je parle même
pas des laboratoires de ville on
n'aimait pas b1 b2 ou pas trop donc en
réalité à l'époque la stratégie c'était
c'est un nouveau virus il est peut-être
potentiellement très très contagieux
c'est dans un pétrin
donc la première chose qu'on a essayé de
faire c'est de faire en sorte que plus
de laboratoire puisse le faire donc on a
fait travailler des experts pour pouvoir
descendre un niveau p2 voilà après moi
mon urgences était que tous les hôpitaux
les aime et on n'était pas du tout dans
la phase épidémique dont je ne peux pas
parler de la phase épidémique
monsieur le rapporteur je peux parler du
moment où j'étais en fonction elle pose
une deuxième question oui c'est une
bonne question mais en fait ce qu'on a
compris moi ce que je comprends de la
grippe h1n1 c'est que il a été reproché
à l'état
globalement d'en faire trop donc il ya
une forme de d'attrition spontanée sans
que soient ré interroger spontanée enfin
une attrition parce qu'il n'y a pas de
stock tournant en fait une attrition
parce qu'on a laissé des stocks dormants
qui en réalité un jour se sont
retrouvées non conformes mais ya pas eu
de travaux spécifiques pour décider de
quelle était vraiment le besoin stocks
stratégiques d'état ça n'a pas été
questionné
je rappelle que nous sommes un des rares
pays à avoir un stock d'état mais cette
question n'a pas été posée
ensuite ce qui est clair c'est que les
recommandations n'ont pas évolué pendant
toute cette période la recommandation
c'est que seuls les gens malades porte
un masque et quand ils sont malades chez
eux
la famille et les soignants évidemment
donc c'est sur cette base là que
résonnent les agences sanitaires donc il
y à l'époque 100 millions de masse c'est
ce que je comprends moi aussi des
missions parlementaires
le directeur de général de la santé
demande à ce qu'on recommande 100
millions de masques
je rappelle que c'est pas que 100
millions de masse on recommande ce jour
là c'est une liste de dizaines de
produits qui sont périmés
enfin n'est pas que des maths et dont on
est sûr l'idée qu'en 2019 on va en avoir
200 millions avec l'idée aussi et c'est
ce que je comprend des perceptions du
rapport avec l'idée qu'il faut être
attentif au fait que la santé puis
france diversifie les producteurs et ça
c'est je crois inscrit je ne sais plus
où je les lui mais l'idée c'est que on
n'est pas un producteur unique
tout ceci n'aurait pas été un problème
si l'épidémie n'était pas parti de voix
en réalité ou de chine
c'est à dire que si l'épidémie était
parti de thaïlande aurait été la chine
se serait mis à produire des masques et
on n'aurait pas été en difficulté mais
ça on le découvre en réalité en janvier
dire que c'est en janvier ou février au
moment où passent commande qu'on se rend
compte que la quasi totalité de la
production mondiale se fait en chine et
moi ministre
je vais vous demander mais interrompre
mais peut-être poser les questions après
vous dire que c'est
c'est toujours pareil ça peut paraître
étonnant si on se dit que la seule
question c'est celle des masques
simplement en 2018
la question c'est des dizaines de
produits s'ils sont des dizaines de
produits et la vigilance que je dois
avoir c'est sur des dizaines de produits
ne me dites pas que des comprimés diodes
en cas d'accident nucléaire ne sont pas
aussi importants ou que des antidotes 2
un neurotoxique ne sont pas aussi
importants en réalité on peut
réinterrogée a posteriori avec ce que
nous avons vécu la façon dont on a
fonctionné mais la façon dont moi je
fonctionne en arrivant comme ministre
c'est une attention portée à la totalité
des stocks stratégiques pas l'un plus
que l'autre et je serai devant vous de
la même façon si j'avais privilégié les
masques plutôt que des tenues ebola
puisqu'en réalité en en 2018 2019 que
créer un mini de la santé c'est beau la
ebola est une urgence de santé publique
de portée internationale déclaré par l'
oms en 2018
parce qu'il ya un foyer à en rdc avec
une nouvelle reprise épidémique en 2019
donc la rdc n'arrive pas à se
débarrasser de gaulle à au point que je
rencontre mon collègue américain de la
santé al aqsa zar que je connais je le
rencontre lors de l'assemblée générale
de l'onu en septembre 2018
nous avons une réunion prévue sur les
prix des médicaments et nous en gamme
rayon immédiatement la discussion sur et
bola parce que nous sommes inquiets tous
les deux parce qu'il y à des vols
directs entre kinshasa et parie qu'on
ait des problèmes des mollahs donc en
réalité la ministre que je suis elle
suit de très près et bola elle suit pas
un virus inconnu qui va arriver un an
plus tard elle suit le risque est le
deuxième risque parce que des
chaussettes en difficulté en syrie le
deuxième risque
c'est un risque d'attentât terroriste
avec quelques informations sur un
potentiel risque chimique est donc en
fait mais deux préoccupation principale
en 2018 2019
ce sont ces deux risques là donc je veux
je peux pas évidemment anticiper une
épidémie mondiale
une pandémie mondiale quelques on a
connu ça peut arriver à tout moment mais
2018-2019 voilà l'objet de mes
préoccupations
voilà pour la première partie de
l'audition d'agnès busin l'ancien
ministre de la santé a réaffirmé avoir
anticipé la crise avoir mis en branle
tout le système dès le 25 janvier sur
les masques à la firme avoir validé des
commandes mais précise qu'une ministre
n'a pas à en connaître les chiffres
la deuxième partie de l'audition d'agnès
bus ainsi que toutes celles de la
commission denquête sont à revivre sur
lcp tout l'été sur notre site internet
lcp point fr